good morning millennials happy friday
hey claude you want to bring us into
today's episode with song yes i do you
guys it
is
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
wow it's friday you guys we [ __ ] did
it we did it that it's just so exciting
that it's friday honestly it's another
like gloomy day here in new york which
made waking up really difficult and it
was made easier knowing that we have two
days of alarm free living coming up and
isn't that something it's really raining
here in pennsylvania too but it's a mood
for sure and we're just rolling into the
weekend you guys like we're feeling
blessed we're feeling de-stressed how
are you feeling jackie another day
another lc update i am feeling okay like
i'm really starting to you know be at my
wit's end right now and the mornings are
when i'm feeling my best and if i'm
coming on here saying like i don't know
then but i can't even imagine what the
afternoon has in store for me
the evenings are just like so
uncomfortable i can't even like i just
i can't
i'm so sorry so close to the end and
your maternity leave starts at the end
of next week we're here we're supporting
you if you need to take a day off you
let me know i'll just talk to myself for
an hour i think people will just love
that um but we're so proud of you we're
so proud of you thank you thank you no
but doing the show really like gets my
spirits up and it's nice to like have
something have some purpose so um i just
need to shake off these like cobwebs i
mean like my neck is just everything
[ __ ] hurts and it's all coming down
at once and it's just really
really crazy and then like my sleep is
getting worse which is affecting my
mornings which were my my best part of
day
when you like walk around your house and
like go pee and stuff do you think like
oh my god my water could break at any
moment i don't think you're there yet i
don't think i don't feel like i'm there
yet and people say um the baby drops
like lower into your belly before it's
time to get ready and i don't know that
baby has dropped okay i don't feel like
i feel like i would know and i don't
think that he has so i think you would
know for sure
so i think i i'm not worried necessarily
about that but when i'm walking around
my apartment i'm just like waddling like
it's so cliche the way that you move
around like hands on belly hands on back
just like from side to side
like a big
big old lady you're a big woman and
we're so excited for you like this is
just the first toast baby like that is
so crazy
it's so crazy can i ask you a question
yeah when are you going home and what
are you what are you doing this weekend
i don't know
you don't have shows you don't have
shows this weekend right no next weekend
so like that's why i've just really been
like
taking it easy ben is away ben was in
florida working and i was on a golf trip
with his friends so i would have been
home alone all week which you know i
[ __ ] hate right right no no and you
know i fully endorsed your decision to
make a week of it i'm just like
wondering uh when you come home
well i'll probably come home after the
weekend because i have a lot of stuff to
do next week and we have an amazing
guest coming in studio next week so
i have to get back to the real world
yeah you're sadly not going to be there
i'm not going to be there but i think
i'll just submit like a list of
questions and you can just like say
these come from jackie please respond
okay cool no problem i have so fomo
i know so i do have to come back next
week so i'm going to spend the weekend
no plans yet but i'm sure it'll be a
granal time
and then i'll officially be back in the
real world but i don't know um that's
the remote podcast life you could do it
from anywhere a farm i'm not complaining
and because you have no clothes like
we're getting skeletons every day
i have no clothing because i was
literally supposed to leave my house on
thursday do shows thursday friday which
requires no clothing just like my
costume and then come home like saturday
or sunday and that was a week ago so
thank god i brought spooky scary and
thank god brian has a premium washing
machine i have been washing them almost
every day which like pains me
because the more i wash it the more
disintegrated these cheap target pajamas
come and i cannot find another pair for
the life of me so it pains me to throw
them in the wash but like i'm walking
around the farm there's horses like i
gotta i gotta wash them yeah you do but
i understand fully i also wanted to give
an update because i said yesterday on
the show that i don't think that there's
anyone out there who's read every single
redheads book and listen to every single
episode and and i offended an entire
community no i was really overwhelmed
and like flooded with responses of
people saying no i am the person i have
done every single book every single
episode there were so many more people
that i would have expected i would have
thought like one two maybe three but
like i got dms to my personal account i
got dms to the redheads account so i'm
just like so
honored that 28 books 28 episodes you
guys are riding with us
i literally told you
i just i couldn't believe it
it's a lot it's a lot of homework
of course but that's what i've been
trying to tell you like the redheads
can't be stopped they can't be stopped
and i actually gave you a book
suggestion um last night
red white and royal blue it was our
second evan ever redheads book and like
the crew didn't love it but i think that
you would and i think you should read it
next
and then you can listen to the episode
my next
my next challenge not challenge but my
next thing on my to-do list is to watch
the hating game movie
um because people actually said it was
really good even though when i was like
reading the book i couldn't see lucy
hale being played as lucy which is just
weird um
i don't know who the man is but like i
just wasn't getting lucy vibes from lucy
got it interesting you've been watching
a lot of tv yeah
like no shade so i want to do a tv recap
okay
literally like
and for me it's nice that i can watch a
lot of tv and not feel like a piece of
[ __ ] because it's literally my job like
i have a full tv recap planned for today
okay about two of the craziest
documentaries i watched last night one
of them is trending right now the tinder
swindler have you ever seen it so i've
heard of it and it looks good so you'll
share with us
i mean it was painful because this man
was like so evil and like jewish and i
was like and he was making his like fake
names so jewish and i'm like we have our
own problems like stop like seriously it
was painful it was painful that part um
but it was really good basically and
i'll do a whole recap but he ran like a
10 million dollar ponzi scheme through
tinder like it was so crazy oh my gosh
okay yeah and then the second thing i
watched was taken at birth which i
haven't finished yet like we were our
eyes were like closing but we needed to
finish so we still like an hour left
it's a six hour documentary
it is the most [ __ ] up it's like three
identical strangers but on some like a
huge scale
taking that birth by who
dr hicks
where is he taking them
so he ran a clinic in georgia in the 60s
and it all happened so long ago they're
having so much hard like such a hard
time finding information he ran a clinic
in the 60s that was known for doing
illegal abortions in like a safe way
and he then turned
that into running like an enormous
adoption ring like selling babies at the
back door for a thousand dollars
oh wow
that sounds over 200 babies well i'm not
gonna watch that at the current junction
but it sounds interesting no no no no
so i want to talk about both of those
in the tv recap um
and then we have a special guest at the
end of the episode and we've got the
fast five so it's gonna be a gorgeous
friday yeah a gorgeous friday and i feel
like a lot of the stories are just like
tying up loose ends from the week and
then we can embark on the weekend like
feeling like we can put this week behind
us we've had answers to some of the
bigger questions that have been asked
this week as you shall see
and i think without further a do to do
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and
before i tell you who today's episode is
brought to you by the olympics started
last night it was the opening ceremony i
know i was gonna be
a part of the stories if you could hold
your horses oh
sure yeah i'll shut up okay today's
episode is brought to you by paint your
life
making new memories in a new world we
have found the best way to hold on to
those memories turning them into
something that lasts forever at
paintyourlife.com
so paint your life i actually happen to
have a gorgeous painted portrait of theo
from it is perhaps my favorite sponsor
you can get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price or you can
combine photos of people or places you
love into one painting i know a lot of
people like to use this service to
paint pictures of people who have passed
away with you know maybe their father
passed away and then they had a baby
that their father never got to meet so
they got they commissioned someone to
paint the two people together and it's
like really emotional it's it's
literally an amazing gift and it's also
just like the best thing for yourself so
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect it's a
super user-friendly platform that makes
it easy to order a custom-made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes and you can receive your
portrait in as little as two weeks so
send any picture yourself your children
your family
and you make the perfect perfect perfect
birthday gift anniversary or wedding
gift it's meaningful personal and can be
cherished forever i love my paint your
life portrait of theo it's perhaps one
of my most prized possessions like there
was a fire i would grab it first that is
so stunning um so i have a paint your
life portrait from my wedding which is
just like it looks like a piece of art
and it's like all the flowers for my
it's stunning but now i need one of
bruce
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk so
if you don't love the final painting
your money's refunded guaranteed and
right now is a limited time offer get 20
off your painting 20 off that's right
and free shipping but only when you use
a special offer by texting morning to 64
000. that's morning to 64 000 to get
free shipping
and 20
off
so morning to 64 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
message and data rates may apply terms
apply available at painterlife.com terms
again that's morning to 64
000
and today's episode is also brought to
you by zip recruiter according to latest
research ninety percent of employees
plan to make enhancing the employee
experience a top priority in 2022 after
all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping great employees
and if you need to add more employees to
your team their zip recruiter their
matching technology helps you find the
right people for your roles fast and
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com toast so zip
recruiter uses its powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
up with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster it's no wonder zip
recruiter is a number one rated hiring
site in the us
based on g2 ratings find the right
employee for your workplace with zip
recruiter try it for free at this
exclusive web address ziprecruiter.com
toast that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ziprecruiter the smartest way
to hire
wonderful thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
doing business with you
[Music]
okay first story some breaking ish news
from kanye because he's taking to
instagram um
to
really ask for help here he posted a
screenshot of north tick tock and said
since this is my first divorce i need to
know what i should do about my daughter
being put on tick tock against my will
i mean i don't think promoting her
account is
is helping you know
no but this is definitely something that
comes up in divorce proceedings like we
see it on you know uh housewives all the
time like when two people get divorced
and then it means that the kids can't
film um this is a really interesting
subject i agree it's drawing more
attention to it right now and like we
know how north loves her tick tock so
that's kind of a bummer
she's not being forced on tick tock
against terrell literally north is
forcing kim against her will to make a
tick tock no but she's on tick tock
against kanye as well like kanye doesn't
improve not against her own will i just
think that's kind of hypocritical like
he doesn't want okay i would understand
if like he was always
keeping north in the dark not in the
public but like didn't he literally have
her perform at his enormous fashion week
show like so just because it's not your
idea like you're unhappy with it he
exploits north all the time ooh
not in a bad way amazing like points are
being made why tick tock why is tick
tock different from all other platforms
i don't know he'll have to explain
himself for that because that is a good
point because ultimately i kind of i
feel this a little bit i mean i just
think
kids are on these platforms too young in
general i agree i also think that going
taking to instagram to share that your
your qualms is not the place to do it
but i also agree with you that north has
very much been on a bigger platform
under bigger spotlights thanks to kanye
and that was okay with him so it's a
little hypocritical
yeah and also like things like this just
give me a pit in my stomach because
whenever kanye is like publicly feuding
on social media with his family in the
past it's just correlated to you know
some of his mental health struggles and
i hope that's not what's going on here
but it just does give me like
reminiscent of you know his twitter
rants which we know was like a really
negative headspace for him so
i hope that they can work it out
privately and and that this doesn't mean
kanye is you know struggling again yeah
but he's oh he said this a few weeks ago
also i think when he was making those
videos in the car on the way to the
birthday party like he's he's been
saying he doesn't like north on tick
tock
no and i i believe that but like handle
it you telling us about it is not going
to help your cause like there's nothing
we can do and he needs to take it up
with the boss herself north
chris
no north is in charge of north's destiny
and if he is having an issue he needs to
talk to north and i really believe this
is one of north's passion projects and
as someone who's like a firm believer in
following your passions and you know
following through on your passion
projects i do support like i do believe
north
she wakes up every day and can't she
can't wait to make a tick tock like it
makes her so happy i really think that
so she's gonna have to explain that to
him i think she's the only one who could
really get through to him and be like
dad i love the talk the talk life is the
best life it is the best life i agree
with you north and i understand and if
someone was trying to take away my tick
tock privileges like they'd have to
fight me for it so i fully support north
in her passion projects
and i fully support kanye and his
wanting limitations for tick-tock
of course so do i but like really
handling it like it makes me feel like
you know what i mean
posting it on instagram agreed i don't
like the way he's handling it the
message itself i think has merited i
think this is probably something that a
lot of parents like this might be
relatable for a lot of parents of you
know uh eight-year-old girls
yeah i mean that's like something that
when i think about in the future like
having to like
talk to my kids about social media like
i'm gonna even though it's like so
hypocritical because it's literally my
whole job like my children will not have
access to social media like after i saw
the social dilemma like what it's doing
to the minds and mental health of our
young girls like i will literally and i
say that now but then like once they're
gonna start crying i just throw them the
phone um
like that's definitely something i think
about a lot like how am i gonna have
that conversation and like what it what
are my parenting rules gonna be as it
pertains to social media and is that
immensely hypocritical of me here's the
thing it sounds hypocritical because
like your whole life is social media and
like you've made your career and you're
living with social media but i think the
more
invested in social media you are like
the more aware you are of all of the
negative consequences as opposed to
someone who just like in partakes just
for fun and when they feel like it so i
actually think that
most people including like celebrities
influencers like they have seen the
darkest sides of social media so they
are the most um
equipped wary of letting their kids use
it
that's actually a really good point but
like i think about that a lot and i'm
not even a mother
yeah no it's it's scary out there and
it's also like
every day every week every month like
it's degenerating further like we're not
trending in an upcoming worse and worse
we're not training in an upwards
positive direction with the social media
comments and behaviors
no it's not a lin it's not linear
progress
no it's
dissension d linear
d linear thank you
is that the right word i don't know i
like literally got wordle in two tries
today so i think i'm like an actual
wordsmith oh my god so i i shared my
wordle yesterday first of all i just
want to let everyone know i did not
guess shart okay
and i could oh by the way it took
everything inside me not to guess shart
yesterday okay because i couldn't share
like i posted my experience on wordle
but i couldn't share about the shark
because i didn't want to give anything
away now that it's a new day i need to
let you know like i did not guess sharp
but i had s-h-a-r for four tries before
i got it i had share i had shark i had
sharp
and then it was sharda but i like that's
not even a word like that was the most
annoying word they could have chosen i
know but i just didn't want to be
associated with the chart so no but you
are
it's too late
i had to clear my name
okay are you ready for our next story of
follow-up to yesterday's story our
little bubble of joy is over because
khloe kardashian is denying dating harry
jowzy
i mean she definitely left it open to
interpretation when she wrote in caps
absolutely not true yeah no i'm not sure
where we landed where we netted on all
of this it's still possible yeah i think
that they're probably it's like early
days for sure
but you know what's so funny is like
harry jowzy's such like a [ __ ] boy like
living for the attention he had posted a
photo dump like of his week and buried
in the middle was this photo of like his
he's sitting in the driver's seat and in
the passenger seat there's all these
flowers and it's like a really nice car
so the du moi tip said flowers and
bentley and he literally put up a photo
of what appears to be flowers and a
bentley so he was obviously like pulled
that from pinterest and just like was
trying to
like he's living for it kind of reminds
me of when like jeffree star jeffree
star was like i'm going to sunday
service
that was funny yeah that was really
funny i mean this was fun while it
lasted also i got it some dms that harry
jowzy had been linked in the past to
larsa
yes okay and they actually spoke about
it on what tv show was it
it was love is blind oh oh wait no
that was okay nevermind um
yeah no it was larsa
okay on like the love is blind reunion
do you remember damian who was engaged
to giannina yeah he had paparazzi
pictures i think with larsa and it
became like a whole thing with francesca
oh yeah yeah okay i'm getting my my
reality stars confused but yes he had
been linked but i think they just like
went to dinner and had he like helped
her to her car and the paparazzi were
outside like i don't think it was a
thing
i don't know i i could ship that too
now that i'm allowed to stand yeah i
mean
literally the one and only um so yes
this is not true our heart is breaking
but you know what what you said
yesterday is entirely possible maybe
this is their meet cute
yeah maybe this is their me cute just
like a hallmark movie and i so i would
say on this like there's definitely a
chance
you know
yeah no i don't know if i would say that
but
i think there's a chance that they just
met yesterday like do you see this crazy
rumor about us yeah we should get drinks
and talk about it you know talk it
through
for sure thinking that through
that is so funny well you know it was
fun while it lasted and to whoever made
it up and submitted it like that's just
really fun and i i believe it's harmless
gossip i mean i hope it didn't cause any
harm to anyone i can't imagine how it
would have but um it was just like a fun
thing for us to all experience
i was thinking about that yesterday like
the person who actually pulled this
rumor out of their ass and decided to
like just [ __ ] with everyone obviously
didn't think it would become like as big
of a thing like to the point where
chloe's responding nobody thought that
and she's probably like either
hysterically laughing in her bedroom or
like freaking out that like people are
gonna find out that it was her and she
started this i think that she is working
on her next rumor and it's not going to
be as good and she's going to get
herself into trouble so if you're
listening to this i would say quit while
you're ahead you've had success here
don't keep going because usually it
doesn't end up like this and people get
big mad
well she is a powerful woman so if she
is listening to this like i wouldn't
mind you starting a harmless rumor about
me like here's some here's some
suggestions okay claudia autry you know
and ben suffer add third to their
relationship john mayer confirms
something like that okay love it i could
believe it i
i don't that's all that's the only one
that's the one i want out there okay
maybe i'll do it
i could believe it too
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i'll do it
that's like the most niche movie
reference that like only our family like
giggles at and i bet okay does anyone in
the world know what this is from
i'll do it i don't give a [ __ ] i'll do
it
no because it's literally the most
random moment in borat from like 15
years ago when he gets in like this rv
with a bunch of college kids like but
it's so random easy people yeah
i'll do it i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll do it
i feel like we stayed a lot on the toes
but we've actually never like explained
what it's from it's from borat and it's
like literally the most
unremarkable scene and i don't know why
like as a family we like we're just very
impacted by that quote and we use it all
the time it's so funny and i think it's
also a great moment to like have a borat
appreciation moment if you're looking
for a great movie to watch this weekend
add it to your list yeah if you're
looking for a great sacha baron cohen
movie to
watch i would suggest which one is
aladine the dictator
that's my favorite one
yeah that one is so good and also oh my
god so you know how we always say every
time and this is like another family
random joke that we always say like when
we take a covet test and it's um
negative we say
negative we say we're covered alladin
and i was actually talking to someone
and i said it i was like oh my god
aladine and they were like someone said
that to me and i didn't know what it
meant
and so someone else is going around
saying covetalidin also but you only say
when you're negative even though it
means positive and negative you only say
when you're negative because if you're
obviously positive you're not making a
joke about it
so for those who don't know what aladine
is it's from the movie the dictator
basically
sacha baron cohen plays a dictator where
he just like changes all the rules in
his country and he makes his last name
aladine mean like 50 different things so
it means positive it means negative so
they cut to this guy at a clinic getting
tested for stds he's like sir your test
was aladdin yay
no
[Laughter]
it's such a good movie
such a good movie definitely watch it i
hope everyone is covered aladdin this
weekend
and then also the theme song of the
movie is
it's the [ __ ] double g
[ __ ] so good
[Laughter]
maybe you should have a sasha baron
covent cohen watch weekend sasha
baronkovic
well actually everything he does is so
funny but do you know that he has i
actually never saw it um he has like a a
serious role it's a short series
um
the spy yeah is that what it's called
yeah i saw it i heard it was amazing
it's amazing yeah it's amazing it's a
lot but you should watch it it's so good
yeah i i always think like i need to
watch that
yeah you definitely should add it to the
of baron cohen
marathon weekend yeah
[Laughter]
okay
annoying but you know i met sasha baron
cohen once and how did that go i've
never actually in my life been so
starstruck like i just stood there i
didn't even i ca honestly met is a
strong word because like we were in a
circle of people and everyone was
talking and i was just like sitting
there because i was like nervous
that's how meats usually go it was
really overwhelming like i had a whole
speech like my jewish king but i didn't
no
no
he doesn't want to hear it not at all
[Laughter]
are you ready for our next story
is it the next story
that's brought to you by
hydro drug yes wow hydra drug is the
perfect friday sponsor
okay so hydra drug if you struggle with
drinking water or you just want to
really like as a resolution start
drinking a good amount of water the
hydro drug is a perfect place to start
so the pro hydro drug the stainless one
or the glass hydro jug my favorite is
the stainless one because i'm like a
beast and i can be like really rough on
it and it like doesn't scratch um it's a
perfect water bottle it's instagram
worthy it's super clean
it keeps your water clean and it cold
but it also looks super cute as well so
the lid is the best part in my opinion
there are no other lids like this on
other water bottles because it includes
a flip cap a dual function sip spout and
a detachable straw so i can sit from the
straw if i'm wearing lipstick and remove
the straw and pour it like normal
um and you know i'm like a straw girly
girl so the fact that the straw is there
but it's also adjustable it's just
wonderful um the stainless steel one has
insulation for hours so it's the upgrade
you need to drink more water their
triple layer insulation will keep your
water cold all day long the jug features
a silicone base to keep it where you
want it and never stress about leaks or
condensation again the fixed handle
makes it easy so you can still drink
one-handed and you won't be able to get
enough of the dual function sip spout
sip through the attached straw or remove
the straw to pour
you're just gonna you're gonna love
everything about it the wide mouth
opening the integrated handle all their
products are bpa free because
sustainability is really important to
them so get your hydro jug at the hydro
jug.com use the discount code toads to
get 10 off your order today hydro drugs
are game changers for anyone on the go
again use code toast at the hydro
jug.com to get 10 off today and start
hydrating today
great thing to do for like top of the
year start drinking more water leave it
on your nightstand it's also just nice
to always have water with you
it really really is water can really
solve a lot of problems i don't think it
could save lives
yeah well definitely that
okay our next story little casting news
dakota johnson is in talks to star in a
spider-man spin-off movie called madame
webb
don't look so excited claudia the 50
shades of gray star is reportedly in
talks to appear in a spider-man spin-off
entitled madame webb for sony pictures
um the character was first introduced in
1980s the amazing spider-man comic she's
described as a mutant mutant who can
predict the future of spidey superheroes
and is usually drawn as an old woman who
is blind and paralyzed she's essentially
surrounded by web-like machinery to help
her light live and stay safe
okay i don't know well i'm feeling all
over the place i think the concept of
like a female spider-man is great
yeah
um
especially one that's like based in
something that comes from the comics not
just like we're going to make a spider
woman today yeah no totally that's like
offensive to women um the thing with
dakota johnson is like i like wanna hate
her because she's like really the face
of nepotism like she got a lead role in
an enormous franchise and i don't think
she'd ever acted a day in her life like
it's the most shocking nepotistic both
of her parents are famous but for some
reason it doesn't bother me because
she's like kind of a queen she's like so
beautiful and funny and she was the
queen who really unraveled the um ellen
story and so for that i feel like we
just have to support this project
yeah i feel like i don't have strong
feelings one way or the other but i do
feel like recently her um
modern family relationship with gwyneth
and chris and everything just like
really
reflects positively on her as a person i
think it's like a really hard situation
to come into and gwyneth just just
posted like this week how much she loves
dakota yeah no by the way i completely
agree with you but i think it says a lot
about gweneth oh well of course but we
already knew that she's like a modern
queen for me like if gwyneth gives her
stamp of approval to anyone especially
someone who's dating the father of her
children like this person must be
exceptional that's exactly what i'm
saying and because we already know that
gwyneth is exceptional and
you know most people i don't know if
they
are
is it the person who's like not
welcoming the new person into the family
or is it the new person that's coming
into the family like it depends most of
the time it depends on the circumstances
i'm sure we can do it to your toasters
with both you know yeah and i'm sure
it's also like a little bit of both like
nobody's perfect so maybe like your
idiosyncrasies just like totally clash
with the other person's flaws as well
yeah i mean i don't know if i could see
dakota johnson playing a superhero but
maybe she's a versatile actress and we
don't know how to be single was a great
movie
right that's funny that you think of how
to be single i'm only thinking of 50
shades but i only saw the first one i've
never seen
that movie was plagued by the fact that
the two of them had absolutely no
chemistry chemistry if anything they had
the opposite of chemistry they had beef
and that really just pops off the screen
you know the thing is we talk about this
all the time like what it takes to make
a great franchise and twilight being you
know the perfect example of two people
who
were deeply in love and that chemistry
translated so much on screen it can have
the opposite effect if i mean kissing
booth two and three jacob lordy and joey
king couldn't even stand each other and
the movie's flopped for a reason yeah
and also i don't want to spoil it for
you because i don't know if you will be
watching victoria ever i will
it's actually not a spoiler but i mean
you know who victoria marries
thank you for asking that's the thing
about historical movies like okay we
watch the irishman spoiler alert if
you've never seen it there's some
character jimmy hoffa and olivia blurts
out oh i wonder who ends up murdering
jimmy hoffa i'm like what jimmy hoffa
dies and she's like he's a real
character you didn't know that she was
being like a an intellectual snob so i
think that like this whole thing about
spoiler alerts and real move like real
historical
there's a gray area because not everyone
knows who victoria married and who the
[ __ ] jimmy hoffa was okay so i won't
give a spoiler on on what happened and
who victoria chooses but the person that
she chooses and that plays out in the
show the entire time they're filming the
show like the two of them are very much
dating in real life jenna coleman and
the actor love
you can feel it come off the screen like
you really really can and so then they
broke up recently which is just like so
sad and victoria's season four there's
been like whispers and it's been delayed
and everything but in the time that you
know they haven't gotten their [ __ ]
together like jenna coleman was spotted
leaving his town house oh
and so maybe
maybe everything will be okay for season
four if we didn't get a season four
which mostly because because i like it
and i found it it's gonna happen it's
also most recently
broke the box office spider-man tom
holland and zendaya being a couple
couldn't hurt i mean i didn't see it but
i imagine the chemistry was palpable
palpable agreed
so so if you want a successful franchise
fall in love with your co-star yeah but
you can't like fake that that's the
thing hollywood can fake a lot of stuff
no i think that's the
je ne sais quoi that's it it's fast
secret sauce yeah and they they can do
all their cgi they can like make [ __ ]
happen but they can't fake love
and i think that's the moral of the
story and you know what's so great like
about twilight even though you know
robert and kristen are long over
she reads not recently but a couple
years after the breakup she did a really
in-depth howard stern interview and
there was a lot of speculation because
it was like so perfect you know this
huge franchise two people fall in love
she was like no no like it was full and
now she's recently come out as gay so i
think a lot of people
question their relationship and she said
in no way was any of it for press none
of it was fake like we were so in love
it's a great interview she does with
howard stern and just to hear that as
like a twilight stand like it brought
tears to my eyes like i got misty-eyed
that's so beautiful
gorgeous i think that's a perfect segue
to our next story which is about another
iconic couple and david beckham is kind
of like spilling the tea on his wife and
saying that she's eaten the same thing
for the last 25 years and of course like
i was like click i believe it what is
she what is cheating
okay while appearing on the latest
episode of river cafe table 4 podcast
david beckham revealed the meal his wife
has eaten since they met in the late
1990s
he said i get quite emotional about food
and wine when i'm eating something great
i want everyone to try it unfortunately
i'm married to someone that has eaten
the same thing for the last 25 years
since i met victoria she only eats
grilled fish and steamed vegetables she
will very rarely deviate away from that
he said the only time she probably ever
shared something that's been on my plate
was actually when she was pregnant with
our daughter harper and it was the most
amazing thing i feel like this is you
and ben
i was just like not to make everything
about me but like reading this and i
said ben easily could have
written it only because i know it's
actually really hard for ben he's such a
foodie and when he goes out he'll order
three things not because he wants to eat
three things but he wants to try and if
he had a partner who could you know
split an appetizer or two like it would
change his life but he doesn't have that
so we literally pay for a meal for like
four people because i get the same thing
every time
i go to a restaurant and i look at the
menu i find either the salmon or the
chicken like that's i will never
ever deviate from that it's just who i
am like i'm a creature of habit ben has
never ordered the same thing twice even
if we go to the same restaurant two
nights in a row he'll get different
things
yeah it really is such a shame because
they do say opposites attract and i'm
sure on some level like you know
subconsciously that's what makes you
guys work is that you're so different
but what about the convenience of like
he could order three things that he
wants to try and then you could also
order things like three things you want
to try and then we tried six things
where does that account
our food and beverage bills would be
half the price if we could share like we
just i don't even know the only thing we
really share is like a side of french
fries and i don't even like to share
those like they're mine we get two yeah
and like he like loves going to new
restaurants and trying like you know
hate
so like hate
and now that i think about it like he's
oh you're never going when he's going
omakase like you're never there
no like if me and men go out to dinner i
go to the same four restaurants like i
love sierra bond i like kaima i like
um
like gemma serafina there's like five
restaurants i'll go to and they're not
even like the best restaurants in the
city they just have [ __ ] there that i
like and i get the same thing every time
we couldn't be more different and i know
it actually like it plagues ben
that's so unfortunate legitimately
legislatively
he has so many friends that want to
share appetizers with him he has so many
friends and now like knowing victoria
and david beckham who have really stood
every test in hollywood so the test of
time 25 years happily married there
might be something to this and maybe
it's just like the fact that you have
your own things like maybe if you guys
were too similar you know then you would
fight over
what you what you would want to order
and try you would also like fight over
like what was the best thing now like
you each have your own thing right he
can tell you what the best thing on the
menu was and you just believe him
well we order it a lot especially you
know since the pandemic started like
even more
and i if it were up to me i would order
the same thing every night i get chicken
teriyaki from sushi seki like it is my
absolute i could eat it till i die and
every time i come home ben's like what
do you want to order i'm like seki and
it like pains him because he's eating
the same thing multiple times a week and
i actually got a notification from
ubereats that i'm in like the top .01 of
people who order from sushi seki and you
know many times i've ordered from sushi
seki in the last year and this was like
a couple weeks ago how many
a hundred
i've been getting those i think that's
crazy
that's crazy i got i get a lot of those
badges these days of like i'm in the top
five percent of customers every
restaurant i order from they're like
you're in the top five percent of
customers i'm like what's everyone else
doing then where are you going like
somebody's in your house some places i
do order from a lot but sometimes i'm
just like you know at once every few
weeks and yeah i guess they are they are
leaving their house but nothing is more
embarrassing than getting those badges i
don't know if ubereats and postmates
like they have to start as a point of
pride but it's humiliating
humiliating to know that i'm in the top
1 of people who order bagels from this
bagel place
when i saw three
digits of the amount of times that i've
ordered from sushi i wanted to literally
die
and it's definitely you know it's not
good business it's not good business
because every time i thought about
ordering food i was like you know what
i'll just go pick something up because i
couldn't stand the shame of my ubereats
app so they should really stop
yeah
agreed
on that note are you ready for our fifth
and final story
i'm not gonna say yeah please sing
everyone wants you to sing it's it's
friday
i want you to sing jackie do you know
what i did yesterday
what did you do
i read some recent podcast reviews okay
oh i read some two the other day
there was one that really bothered me
there was one that bothered me me too
but i can't remember mine was yours
did they recently start doubling up how
many ads they do it's literally the
whole show
i'm like okay so we do a 60-minute
episode we do three maybe four ads one
minute each so four minutes out of 60 is
the whole show wench and this is a
business [ __ ] like we have [ __ ] to do
wench wait i'm dying such a wenchy
comment you guys i'm gonna give you a
little like uh trick of the trade for
podcasts pretty much for every 15
minutes is one ad so if we're doing an
hour show
that's four ads and so we're not doing
any more or less ads than we're supposed
to be doing i don't really wanna okay i
just pulled up um oh my god i'm not even
gonna look quickly i can't remember what
it was under my feelings i can't
remember what it was that hurt my
feelings but um and there were a lot of
negative ones but sometimes they don't
hurt i'm like okay that's your opinion
cool yeah there was just like something
that um
i think i know what it was because i saw
it too was it like really complimentary
to me and like really nasty to you what
was the nastiness to me
it was just like claudia is a born
entertainer which was so nice oh no i
haven't seen this oh and then it was
like and jackie's just like monotone and
she ends every sentence with a g i don't
even know what that meant
with a g
okay you don't have to look out for that
but no that wasn't that wasn't even it
well what actually there was like two
that actually really bothered me because
i guess some people didn't like what we
had to say about jenny nguyen and they
were like okay well if this was about
the jewish community you know they only
care about things that
relate to them and then it's like
literally the next week we had a whole
segment on whoopi goldberg's
anti-semitism and i think we literally
gave the same amount we literally said
the same thing to jenny that we said
about the same principle and because we
are principled people that's what's nice
about having principles you can just
apply them to everything and you'll be
consistent i saw those comments um
on the jenny when episode and i was just
like is this your first time listening
because when have we ever gone harder
against someone if anything i feel like
we're more forgiving when someone
insults the jewish community because we
just like don't want to believe that
like people have hated that amount of
hate in their hearts you know and i
really feel like i'm extremely
inconsistent in most facets of my life
like i'm extremely hypocritical um but i
actually feel like when we talk about
cancer culture i feel like i'm very
equal when it's like a community that
i'm a part of or a community that i'm
not a part of that's like something i
actually like to pride myself on so i
didn't appreciate that and i'm never
reading podcast reviews again
uh yeah well i just like scroll down to
some and now i'll try and find the one
that just don't do it no jackie you're
pregnant and you need to protect your
aura and your energy and seriously i'll
kill you if you do it okay okay great
but there's like whatever
sometimes there's something in there i'm
like you know what that's actually some
pretty good feelings yes of course let's
incorporate that it's important to know
like sometimes people actually do give
critical feedback like in a helpful nice
way and they don't give you one star
they're like i love this show four stars
but could you just do this thank you
yeah agreed agreed okay are you ready
for our fifth and final story now which
you're not gonna sing because you've
been cause i've been silenced you've
been silenced well it's about the winter
olympics which kicked off last night
opening ceremonies of the 2022 winter
olympics today is our first day of
activities
they are taking place in beijing which
is 13 hours ahead of the east coast so
it's like very
you know there's the live but then
there's also going to be prime time and
it's going to be confusing because did
the opening ceremonies aired last night
i don't know brian didn't want to watch
it we were like stuck in this
documentary that i'm going to talk about
in five minutes i did not see one thing
where about anyone watching
where's the opening
i have no idea
yeah no i thought the same thing there's
like very little energy being put
towards i think it's because it's like
controversial
well here no here yes it is
controversial but also the opening
ceremony will air in prime time tonight
oh okay good it's ready to happen okay
yeah and i was thinking why would it
premiere on a thursday that's just like
not good television that's not the show
business if you're looking for premium
coverage of the olympics i highly
suggest following leslie jones on all
social media platforms she watches every
single minute of it and she records
herself and her reactions and seriously
the fact that nbc hasn't hired her like
an official capacity as an olympic
correspondent is devastating because
she's so funny it's like my favorite
thing to watch um and as far as i know
she's literally the only person talking
about it
yeah but there hasn't been much to talk
about yet but today we will have
activities starting at 12 noon um
eastern time
but then the opening ceremony will air
tonight so it's just it's confusing all
over the place very much so okay well
that's very exciting there's also a
historic um moment happening for israel
the first modern orthodox woman is an
olympian and she is competing so i just
you know what to say
um that's as far as i know okay i've
only read the headline we'll have to
watch the opening ceremony to find out
yeah very exciting so i love the
olympics i will be tuning in but i do
agree there's like a lack of energy a
lack of momentum lack of
spirit
for the winter olympics and i just think
the winter olympians deserve more it's
also sean white's last olympics like
there's a lot it's a historic season oh
wow he's
oh i didn't realize that he was um
retired competing i thought he was going
to be like
broadcasting no i think uh you know let
me just double check my facts because
you know i like to make no you sound
right he's like still does his thing
he's so cute you know he's dating nina
dobrev of course i know ship so hard
sean white on 22 winter olympics it's
tough to say goodbye so yeah i think
this is his last one
very cool and him and nina joe are ever
actually extremely cute extremely
i'm happy for them me too okay well
those are the past five stories i feel
as though you needed to know them and
now claudia's gonna share everything
that she's been watching before you do
let me just say i started season five of
poldark i finished with my break i know
how you love when i talk about poldark
claudia you're just like can i tell you
what
what did ross do what did demelza say
can i tell you something yeah
i have literally no idea what poldark is
like you keep talking about it i'm like
it took me a while to figure out it was
a tv show like i'm seriously like i'm so
confused every time you talk about it
okay it is a tv show it's a period piece
it is set now where it's 1800 in london
um they do live in cornwall most of the
time and it's just they don't live in
illyria
they know but of course that's what i
was thinking it's just a historical
fiction uh television show
on amazon prime there's five seasons and
if you're into that sort of thing like
it is a really good show it has really
good moments but it's also incredibly
frustrating and so i watched four
seasons and i needed a break from it
from ross poldark and his antics
i just came back for season five because
i just want to close the book on it
season five is somehow even more
frustrating than all the other seasons
so i just need to plow through
and get to the end because um they're
really just like driving the show into
the ground no offense
and t the shade yeah but i would still
like recommend it if you're into that
sort of thing but this is what happens
with all television shows you know
there's only so much you can do and it's
like you don't want to cause too much uh
strife and controversy within the show
because then like your faves might get
broken up and like i don't want to see
that for ross and demelza i do ship so
it is what it is but it's also very
frustrating so i will finish that this
weekend i'm actually really excited to
start real houses of miami now that i am
like a larsa stan i'm gonna make i'm
gonna make an instagram fan account stop
larson stand for life um okay well the
tv recap is brought to you by sunbasket
who's ready to feel amazing this year
sun basket delivers healthy meals so you
aren't on the hook to shop and cook to
hit your health goals because old habits
die hard so if you're looking to kick
off the new year with healthy eating
habits check out sun basket meals they
deliver the joy of eating food with bold
flavors organic produce and sustainable
seafood and meats their award-winning
chefs are constantly innovating with new
recipes and global tastes to keep it
interesting each week
they have dozens of options their fresh
and ready meals are perfect hot lunch
hack eat eat and eat in minutes and you
can put dinner on autopilot with easy to
prep meal kits that impress for date
night to win over picky eaters in your
family i'm extremely picky we literally
just spoke about that for 20 minutes and
there's so much variety when it comes to
sun basket they have really good food
and if you're not like
you know chef boyardee
the heat and eat is very easy to use and
i just i love i love it um they've got
also healthy snacks grab and go
breakfast items
whether you eat vegetarian paleo gluten
free or low carb high protein sunbasket
has something to check any and every box
and right now sun basket is offering 90
off in a free gift when you order go to
sunbasket.com
toast and enter the promo code toast at
checkout that's sunbasket.com
toast enter promo code toast to check
out you will not regret it so the two
documentaries that i watched the first
one which was like a little bit lighter
was the tinder swindler and i told you
it's this man who literally used tinder
in europe to
do a ponzi scheme of over 10 million
dollars he told everyone he was like the
son of this really rich israeli guy
um so he took his name but the guy had
no sons so like literally
these girls who he was he was meeting
them on tinder took them on a private
jet their first date and it turned out
like with every girl he was like
swindling he was using money from a
previous girl so he would get in
relationships with them buy them
everything they want and then the money
runs out and he's like oh my god all my
diamond he's in the diamond business all
my diamond enemies are on to me they're
trying to kill me he sends pictures of
like fake blood
he's like oh my god i don't i can't
they're tracing my credit cards can you
just like let me your credit card and he
would run up these crazy charges make
the women take out loans most of them
are now in debt for 250 000
each
it was a crazy story and the women
really got the story to be told and got
him arrested they contacted the biggest
paper in norway two of the women sat
down and then once the article came out
all these women all over europe like
london oslo norway started to come
forward
and they the woman who actually ended up
facilitating his arrest
was this queen like queen okay but she
was so pissed before she turned him in
she was like literally i'm 140 000 in
debt and if he gets turned in like i'm
[ __ ] so he was telling her like i need
money i need money i need money she's
like okay i have a great idea let me
sell all your designer clothes for you i
work in luxury fashion i will sell all
your designer clothes i'll come to i
think he was in amsterdam he's like i'll
come pick it up and then i'll send you
the money so he's so desperate he's like
okay amazing she goes she takes three
enormous suitcases of all of his
designer clothes that he's acquired over
the years and starts listing them on
ebay
and she never told us how much she ended
up making she said she didn't make back
the full amount but like it was enough
to make a dent and really like screw him
over because after that he was like
spending twelve dollars a night to live
in a hostel and she found out what name
he was gonna use for his next life he
kept changing his name and she reported
him to the police and he got arrested he
literally did 15 months in prison he got
sentenced to 15 sorry he only stayed for
five he's out and about he's free now
living his best life these women are
still in debt and when they take out
these loans they have crazy interest
rates so they keep making payments but
they're [ __ ] like they're
whatever so the whole thing was really
interesting because his instagram he was
posing as simon levive
the son of this heiress of the lld
diamonds llc diamonds is a real company
that has absolutely nothing to do with
this and they had to post a statement on
their instagram being like we're like a
small business like we have nothing to
do with this man leave us alone but i
went to simon's instagram last night and
he had 159 000 followers and he was on
private i was like [ __ ] i wanted to talk
then when we finished the documentary i
checked again he hit 175 000 and he was
on public and i saw that we had a mutual
friend and i was like oh my god
i'm freaking out
so i texted my friend and i was like
it's so funny i'm like
how do you know simon levive
he goes
ha ha
i don't i'm like but why do you guys
like why do you follow him i just watch
a documentary and i'm obsessed
and i just want to say like the fact
this person is like a man about town he
runs in fabulous circles like he would
know it wasn't shocking at all yeah so
i'm like why do you follow him i just
watch a documentary and i'm obsessed he
goes because i just watched the
documentary also oh my god and i
immediately followed him i thought i
literally thought we had a mutual friend
he was like no no i just watched
documentary and i thought it was so
crazy i thought you were going to say
that so like found someone that you're
friends with who like thought this guy
is who he says he is and like was going
to be his next victim
i thought i was about to blow my
friend's mind being like simon levi is
not who you think he is his name is
simon haywood like
but it wasn't that is so and then the
next thing i watched is this three-part
tlc documentary called taken at birth
about the dr hicks babies which i had
never heard of but in 1997 this article
came out and blew this whole thing wide
open
basically there was a man in georgia
who was running like a clinic but it was
well-known underground for being like a
safe place to get an illegal abortion
because you know back in the day you
couldn't get an abortion if you did it
was really dangerous and he was like
known for like taking care of all these
women
and it turns out that he was running
this incredibly
[ __ ] up adoption ring where he was
either women came to him to give birth
and he would tell them that their babies
died and then be selling the baby out
the back door for a thousand dollars to
like random women across the country who
were infertile
or women would come for an abortion and
he was like i guess some like pro-life
activist who would be like no listen
keep the baby and i will take care of it
for you
so
he would keep these women pregnant until
like 30 weeks and have them like induced
so these babies would be like tiny this
woman said i came to pick up my daughter
and i could fit her in both my hands
like and they like it was just so it was
so [ __ ] up
and so now all these hicks babies who
have like recently found each other are
trying to find their lineage they're
trying to find their birth parents
there's no documentation because all of
their birth certificates are fraudulent
like
and because it has their it has their
adopted parents names on their birth
certificate so thanks to 23andme and
like ancestry like
some people are able to find like close
relatives this was also the 50s so most
of these people's parents have passed
away without ever finding out that they
had a child they literally thought this
woman thought she gave birth to two
stillborn twins and we found one of them
steven like it's so [ __ ] up
oh my god but wait so the people who
gave birth to and then he said that the
babies died like they wanted to keep
their babies yes they just came to give
birth
oh my god it's so horrible and like the
town is really weird because like
there's a lot of old people who live in
the town who were around during that
time
and
it was like a well-known thing that he
was doing like they all kept his secret
he was like this honorable man who
everyone loved but like people knew
about it like it's not like this is
coming as a shock the town is like
trying to cover it up and it's like
really [ __ ] up there's just like a lot
of creepy things happening but where i
left off last night
is that
there's a chance
they exhumed the body of dr hicks's son
to get dna because he died about 40
years ago dr hicks himself died like a
million years ago so they exhumed his
body to get dna from the sun because
they think a lot of these babies
are related to dr hicks like he was
[ __ ] around on the side him and his
son were both [ __ ] around on the side
and were literally like taking these
babies from the women that they got
pregnant and giving them to families who
were struggling with fertility
so last night they exhumed the body we
have to get the dna i don't know what's
going to come of it but it's the most
think do you think that they were
intentionally getting women pregnant so
that they had babies to sell
i don't know it's the thing is it's like
this happened so long ago there's like
no information they're literally like
grasping at straws oh my god that is so
[ __ ] spooky it makes my stomach hurt
it's pittsfield don't watch it like it's
really [ __ ] up no no i don't think i'm
in a position but if you're not pregnant
if you're not pregnant i highly
recommend tlc did a stand-up job
wow that's insane
insane so that's my tv recap sorry it's
a little dark but i was in a document
documentary mood yesterday
you can't help these things honestly a
documentary mood is a pretty good mood i
need to i need to
i need to see where my tv path is going
to take me next i really never do not
know check out the tinder swindler it
was kind of crazy yeah i might i like
that that sounds like american greed and
they all like he was
communicating with all his different
girlfriends on whatsapp and they have
everything they have all he loved to
send voice memos so like you hear him
yelling and going crazy he was always
sending videos like miss you baby on
like a on a private plane so like it's
really embarrassing for him and they
have like a lot of footage from all the
whatsapp chats oh wow
so good
thanks for sharing
um it's a pleasure
so that's our show for now if you're
gonna continue watching we have a great
segment that's brought to you by bacardi
and that's all she wrote thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found spotify
itunes stitcher public radio ir radio
cast box all the places wherever you
listen to podcasts find us morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
how we are principled queens have a
great day everyone we'll see you on
monday and enjoy your weekend be safe
bye welcome back to the morning toast we
are so excited for our next segment
which is brought to you by the bacardi
party tour we are sitting down with joe
and andrew from loud luxury who are
headlining the bacardi party tour and
just happened to be two of my favorite
people to follow on tick tock so welcome
to the toast thank you guys so much for
being here thank you for having us so
can you tell us a little bit about the
bacardi party tour like where have you
been so far what stops do you have left
what are you looking forward to
i mean we've been all over it's been a
pretty wild ride um all the shows have
been probably some of the best shows
we've done this year which we're super
super thankful for just uh coming out of
the pandemic and actually being able to
tour again
um
so we're super super excited for the
rest of the shows
that's so fun what has it been like
working with bacardi and how are you
guys going to close out this tour it's
been awesome working with bacardi you
know i they really believe in what we're
doing not just
um on the show side but also on the
music side we've collaborated on some
really awesome things we even actually
made our own drink together for the tour
so it's really a top-down experience
from the second that you step into one
of these parties where it feels like
it's a true collaboration between loud
luxury and bacardi so we know the tour
is in full swing can you tell us your
favorite stop along the bacardi party
tour and why
uh well i mean
all of them have been amazing uh the
shows have been literally ten out of ten
uh one of them that was really special
was uh in pennsylvania uh we got to be
there for halloween we got to spend some
time there and that's always a great
place to just kind of hang out
but i mean indiana texas uh we've done
ah georgia
um minnesota all of them have been great
seeing this great nation i personally
i personally loved college station
because we got the most texas experience
of all time there we ate fried gator we
went to this country bar after it was
like
the most texas experience you could
possibly get and that was really cool to
us because normally we're just in dallas
and more like the metropolitan cities
wow that's such a fun way to see like
all of our different cities in our great
nation like through the lens of the
colleges
through partying yes yes
this tour sounds like honestly a dream
like the most fun a person could
possibly have the bacardi brand ethos is
do what moves you how do you guys feel
like loud luxury embodies this does what
moves you guys i mean the only thing
we're thinking about when we're in the
studio is just are people gonna dance to
this is this gonna get people going when
we're playing songs for people we're
literally just watching and just seeing
how their body reacts like that is
literally the fundamental thing of what
you do in dance music so i think bacardi
and us have that in common now not to
get too personal but what moves you both
of you
i mean we we honestly really love this
tour because it kind of brings us back
to
our college days um i mean that's that's
the big big thing for us is going back
to all these great colleges and
um really just like getting to play all
of our new music because all the music
that we made was during the pandemic so
we didn't really have
um
a time to really play it out for anybody
other than like on live streams or like
anything like that so
um for us it's really been special being
able to play all the new music out for
people
and i know this is like asking your
favorite child but what is your favorite
bacardi cocktail well the luxe lemonade
because that's the one that we did
together
yeah the luxe lemonade for sure but that
sounds it sounds delicious yes it's it's
actually really simple to make how do
you make it
walk us through it yeah deluxe lemonade
is actually super simple to make yeah
all right so
what you need is you need bacardi limon
which is actually amazing and i wasn't
really a rum drinker until this so i
love bakari lemon and then you just mix
it with some lemonade i think it's one
and one and a half ounces of bacardi
lemon with three ounces of lemonade and
you put in a tall glass tons of ice give
it a quick stir and then you're set and
we've been drinking that the whole tour
and loving it
that sounds so good i'm about to um give
birth but once i do that sounds
definitely can't be drinking at that
refreshing way
let's celebrate
we'll make you a nice lemonade we'll let
you know i'm getting
just i'm getting prepared for you know
what i can look forward to and that
sounds like something i should add to my
list of things
people get excited like what's going to
be my first drink
oh yeah
people get excited like what's going to
be my first drink after birth yeah a lot
of people have asked me like what's
going to be the first thing i'm gonna
eat that i couldn't eat before like
activity that i couldn't do before but
for first drink like this is definitely
up there of something that um i've gotta
try that just honestly sounds really
refreshing and a great foray back into
the world of alcohol for sure
we'd love a good food well if we make it
to the bacardi party
we'll have one all together yeah
hopefully we can pass one of the shows
claudia would love that she's just dying
to oh oh my god i live her college days
because she went to a school in a city
she did not have like the real
experience i think claudia needs to
become a groupie for the
headline hey you're welcome on stage any
time groupie jackie i'm married
she just means you're gonna come to some
shows with us
you know i did just release a song that
is it's critically acclaimed like it's
up for a peabody it's up for a nobel
peace prize and maybe you guys just
listened to it and you let me know what
you think it's on spotify it's called
100 percent by claudia ashrae you check
it out you let me know
we will 100
pun intended
claude you gotta get yourself on this
tour i think i think it'll catch you up
for like years worth of college partying
that you missed
i think it's also what my music career
really needs
yeah
the fomo is real
what do you guys usually do
to get ready to celebrate game day
it's a good question
i mean for us we like to wake up the
good thing about game days that's early
so you get to wake up and have a really
nice breakfast i'm personally a sucker
for the chick-fil-a breakfast
that was one of my favorite parts of
going to athens georgia when we played
there is that it's just chick-fil-a at
every street corner that was the only
thing that
because it was right before game day and
that's the one tip you just got to make
a reservation because
literally we tried to eat pretty much at
every single bar that was or like food
spot or whatever it was just on the
strip
everywhere was a minimum hour wait and
the only thing that we didn't have to
wait in a crazy crazy line for was
chick-fil-a there's still a line but
we were
we got to eat there
that sounds like a yeah it sounds like a
blessing in disguise
yeah i've never been to a number one
ranked football school the atmosphere is
totally different especially before
every game day because there's just so
much riding on that game
so the city it feels like it it's like
you know
a stick of dynamite that's about to just
explode like the energy is contagious
and we felt that playing the show too in
georgia as well is that everyone is just
so hyped has so much energy it was
really special and
beyond the bacardi party chart you guys
also just released your ep holiday hills
yeah so like i was saying earlier yeah
we made that pretty much
over the entirety of the pandemic um i
mean we had nothing but time so
it was a big adjustment just kind of
going from playing shows all the time
and traveling and
you know doing that whole thing to
basically having all the time in the
world on our hands so uh we were able to
really just like kind of sit down make
some music and
um
work on some some new stuff for everyone
so that that was a blessing in disguise
also because i mean that's one thing
about being on the road and touring so
much is actually really hard to
really sit down and focus on making
music right yeah wow what's your
favorite what's your guys's each
personal favorite loud luxury song it's
like asking to pick between your
favorite child
i know a dna choice that's what we call
it here at the morning toast
yes
well personally my favorite type of
music is music i create myself so i feel
like that's an unfair question but you
guys got to remix it
okay so you get it then why would you
ask us that yeah you know
that's true that's actually fair touche
andrew touche
okay so
there's a lot going on with you guys but
what can your fans really expect to see
and hear from you you next
well we got two more stops on the
bacardi party tour we're keeping that
train running even starting with this
weekend we're playing at columbia
missouri and that's going to be a really
awesome show because last time we came
there was a halloween show on our bus
tour yeah yeah that was a halloween show
on a crazy tour and it was honestly one
of our favorite shows we've ever done
hopefully a very cold time of the
year oh
yeah well so for anyone listening the
bacardi party tour is making its next
stop in columbia missouri february 5th
21 plus rsvp only post game celebration
of the tigers vs aggies basketball game
from 9 00 p.m until midnight so you
don't want to miss it it sounds super
fun i think i might have to fly out
tonight
yeah and then after that party we're
keeping it going on the 19th
yeah on the 19th of february
the 19th of february we're going to be
in tempe arizona
which is honestly one of our favorite
places to play we love it that's always
great for that one as well that's always
a crazy time so you have two left that
you can uh arizona's fun on stage with
us
so if anyone wants to rsvp for the last
events go to bacardi party tour dot com
joe andrew thank you guys so much for
being here good luck with the rest of
the tour and just let me know about that
collab you just let me know thank you so
much anytime
thank you so much bye guys have a great
one bye yes
bye everyone